hi I want to talk about understanding
and the nature of understanding and what
the essence of understanding is because
understanding is something we aim for
everyone we own what we want to
understand things my claim is that
understanding has to do with the ability
to change your perspective if you don't
have that you don't have understanding
so that is my claim and I want to focus
on mathematics many of us think of
mathematics as addition subtraction
multiplication division fractions
percent geometry algebra all that stuff
but actually I want to talk about the
essence of mathematics as well and my
claim is that mathematics has to do with
patterns behind me you see a beautiful
pattern and this pattern actually
emerges just from drawing circles in a
very particular way so my day-to-day
definition of mathematics that I use
every day is the following first of all
it is about finding patterns and with a
pattern I mean a connection a structure
some regularity some rules that govern
what we see second of all I think it is
about representing these patterns with
the language we make up language if we
don't have it and in mathematics this is
essential it's also about making
assumptions and playing around with
these assumptions and just seeing what
happens and we're going to do that very
soon and finally it's about doing cool
stuff
mathematics enables us to do so many
things so let's have a look at these
patterns if you want to tie a tie knot
there are patterns tie knots have names
and you can also do the mathematics of
tie knots this is a left out right and
center out and tie this is a left and
right out left and center out and tie
this is a language we made up for the
patterns of tunnels
and a half-windsor is all that this is a
mathematics book about tying shoelaces
at the university level because there
are patterns in shoelaces you can do it
in so many different ways we can analyze
it we can make up languages for it and
representations is all over mathematics
this is Leibniz notation from 1675 he
invented a language for patterns in
nature when we throw something up in the
air it falls down why we're not sure but
we can represent this with mathematics
in a pattern this is also a pattern and
this is this is also an invented
language and yet can you guess for what
it is actually a notation system for
dancing for tap-dancing and that enables
him as a choreographer to do cool stuff
to do new things because he has
represented it and I want you to think
about how amazing representing something
actually is here it says the word
mathematics but actually they're just
dots right so how in the world can these
dots represent the word well they do
they represent the word mathematics and
these symbols also represent that word
and this we can listen to sounds like
this some of these sounds represent the
word and a concept how does this happen
and there's something amazing going on
about representing stuff so I want to
talk about that magic that happens when
we actually represent something here you
see just lines right with different
width they stand from numbers for a
particular book and I can actually
recommend this book it's a very nice
book just trust me
okay so let's just do an experiment just
play around with some straight lines
this is a straight line let's make
another one so every time we move we
move one down and one across and we will
draw a new straight line right so we do
this over and over and over and we look
for patterns so this pattern emerges and
it's a rather nice pattern it looks like
a curve right just from drawing simple
straight lines
now I can change my perspective a little
bit I can rotate it I don't have a look
at the curve you know what does it look
like is it a part of a circle it's
actually not the part of a circle so I
have to continue my investigation and
look for you know the true pattern or
perhaps if I copy it and make some art
well no perhaps I should extend the
lines like this and look for the pattern
there and let's make more lines we do
this and then let's just zoom out and
change our perspective again and then we
can actually see that what started out
is just straight lines is actually a
curve called the parabola this is
represented by a simple equation at it
and it's a beautiful pattern so this is
the stuff that we do we find patterns
and we represent them and I think this
is a nice day-to-day definition but
today I want to go a little bit deeper
and think about what is the nature of of
this what makes it possible and there's
one thing that's a little bit deeper and
that has to do with the ability to
change your perspective and I claim that
when you change your perspective and if
you take another point of view you learn
something new about what you are
watching or looking at or hearing and I
think this is a really important thing
that we do all the time
so let's just do look at this simple
equation like X plus x equals 2 times X
this is a very nice pattern and it's
true because 5 plus 5 equals 2 times 5
etc and we've seen this over and over
and we represent it like this but think
about it this is an equation it says
that something is equal to something
else and that's two different
perspectives one perspective is it's a
sum it's something you plus together on
the other hand it's a multiplication and
those are two different perspectives and
I would go as far as to say is every
equation is like this every mathematical
equation where you use that sign that
equals design is actually a metaphor
it's an analogy between two things
you're just viewing something and taking
two different points of view and you're
expressing that in the language have a
look at this equation this is one of the
most beautiful equations and it simply
says that
well two things they're both negative
one this this thing on the left hand
side is negative one and the other one
is and that I think is one of the
essential parts of mathematics you take
different points of view so let's just
play around let's take that number you
know we know 4/3 we know what 4/3 is
it's 1 point 3 3 3 but we have to have
those three dots otherwise it's not
exactly 4/3 but this is only in base 10
you know the number system we use ten
digits if we chase that around and only
use two digits that's called the binary
system it's written like this so we're
now talking about the number the number
is 4/3 and we can write it like this and
we can just change the base change the
number of digits and we can write it
differently so these are all
representations of the same number we
can even write it simply like one point
three or one point six it all depends on
how many digits you have or perhaps we
should simplify and just write it like
this I like this one because this is 4/3
and this number expresses a relation
between two numbers you have 4 on the
one hand and 3 on the other and you can
visualize this in many ways and what I'm
doing now is I'm viewing that number
from different perspectives and playing
around and playing around with how we
view something and I'm doing it very
deliberately we can take a grid if it's
four across and three up this line
equals five always it has to be like
this this is a beautiful pattern four
and three and five and this rectangle
which is four by three you've seen a lot
of times this is your average computer
screen 800 by 600 or 1600 by 1200 is the
television or the or a computer screen
so these are all nice representations
but I want to go a little bit further
and just play more with this number here
you see two circles I'm not going to
rotate them like this and observe the
upper left one it goes a little bit
faster right you can see this and it
actually goes exactly four thirds as
fast and that means that when it goes
around four times the other one goes
around three times now let's make two
lines and draw this duct where the lines
meet we get this dancing dot around and
this dot comes from that number
right now we should trace it let's trace
it and see what happens this is what
mathematics is all about it's about
seeing what happens and this emerges
from 4/3
I like to say that this is the image of
4/3 it's a very much nicer thank you
this is not new this has been over for a
long time but so but this is four-thirds
let's do another experiment let's now
take a sound this sound this is a
perfect a 440 Hertz let's multiply it by
two we get this song we play them
together so this is an octave right I
can do this game we can play a sound
played same a and multiply it by three
halves that's this is for what we call a
perfect fit real nice together let's
multiply this sound by four thirds right
what happens you get this sound this is
the perfect fourth if the first one is
an eight this is a D it sound like this
together this is the sound of four
thirds what I'm doing now I'm changing
my perspective I'm just viewing a number
from another perspective I can even do
this with rhythms right I can take a
rhythm and play three beats at one time
in a period of time and I can play
another sound four times in that same
space okay it sounds kind of boring but
listen to them together
hey so I can even make you make little
higher you can hear this so this is the
sound of four thirds again
this is acid rhythm I like to keep doing
this and play games with this number
four thirds is a really great number I
love four thirds you're good I mean
truly is a undervalued number I mean so
if you take a sphere and look at the
volume of this where it's actually four
thirds of some particular cylinder so
four thirds is in this fair is the
volume of the sphere okay so why am i
doing all this well I want to talk about
what it means to understand something
and what do we mean by understanding
something that's my aim here and my
claim is that you understand something
if you have the ability to view it from
different perspectives let's look at
this letter is a beautiful are right how
do you know that well as a matter of
fact you've seen a bunch of ours and
you've generalized and abstract it over
all these and you
the pattern so you know the decision
this is an R so what what I'm aiming for
here is saying something about how
understanding and changing your
perspective is linked and I'm a teacher
and I'm a lecturer and I can actually
use this to teach something because when
I give someone else another story a
metaphor and analogy if I tell a story
from a different point of view
I enable understanding I make
understanding possible because you have
to generalize over everything you see
and hear if I give you another
perspective that will become easier for
you let's do a simple example again this
is four and three this is four triangles
so this is also four thirds in a way
let's just join them together now we're
going to play a game we're going to fold
it up into a three dimensional structure
I love this this is a square pyramid
okay and let's just take two of them and
just put them together okay so this is
what is called the octahedron it's one
of the five platonic solids now we can
quite literally change our perspective
because we can rotate around one of the
axes and view it from different
perspectives and I can change the axis
and then I commute from another point of
view but it's the same thing but it
looks a little bit different and I can
do it even one more time and every time
I do this something else appears so I'm
actually learning more about the object
when that changed my perspective I can
use this as a tool for creating
understanding I can take two of these
and just put them together like like
this and see what happens and it looks a
little bit like the octahedron I have a
look at that if I spin it around like
this what happens well if you take two
of these join them together and spin it
around
there's your octahedron again a
beautiful structure if you lay it out
flat on the floor this is the octahedron
this is the brass structure of an
octahedron and you can even I can
continue doing this you can draw three
great circles around the octahedron and
they rotate around
so actually three great circles is
related to the octahedron and if you
take a bicycle pump and just pump it up
you can see that this is
so a little bit like the octahedron yes
do you see what I'm doing here I am
changing the perspective all the time so
let's now take a step back and that
that's actually a metaphor stepping back
and have a look at what we're doing I'm
playing around with metaphors and
playing around with perspectives and
analogies I'm telling one story in
different ways
I'm telling stories I'm making a
narrative and I'm making several
narratives and I think all these things
makes understanding possible I think
this actually is the essence of
understanding something I truly believe
this so this thing about changing your
perspective it's absolutely fundamental
for humans let's play around with this
earth let's zoom into the ocean have a
look at the ocean we can do this with
anything we can take the ocean and view
it up close we can look look at the
waves we can go to the beach we can view
the ocean from another perspective every
time we do this we learn a little bit
more about the ocean if we go to the
shore we can kind of smell it right you
can hear the sound of the waves you can
feel salt on their tongues so all these
are different perspectives and this is
the best one we can go into the water we
can see the water from the inside and
you know what this is absolutely
essential in mathematics and computer
science if you're able to view a
structure from the inside then you
really learn something about it
that's some of the essence of something
so when we do this and we're taking this
journey into the ocean we use our
imagination and I think this is one
level deeper and it's actually a
requirement for changing your
perspective let's we can do a little
game you can actually imagine that
you're sitting there you can imagine
that you're up here and that you're
sitting here you can view yourselves
from the outside that's really a strange
thing
you're changing your perspective you're
using your imagination and you're
reviewing yourself from the outside and
that requires imagination and
mathematics and computer science is the
most imaginative art forms ever and this
thing about changing perspectives should
sound a little bit familiar to you
because we do it every day and then it's
called empathy when I view the world
from your perspective I have empathy
with you if I really truly understand
what the world looks like from your
perspective I am empathetic that
requires imagination and that is how we
obtain understanding and this is all of
our mathematics and this is all of our
computer science and there's a really
deep connection with between empathy and
these Sciences so my conclusion is the
following understanding something really
deeply has to do with the ability to
change your perspective so my advice to
you is try to change your perspective
you can just study mathematics it's a
wonderful way to train your brain
changing your perspective makes you
makes your mind more flexible it makes
you open to new things and it makes you
it makes you able to understand things
and use yet another metaphor it's have a
mind like water that's nice thank